speaking of Music AI music has taken
over the entire world
I mean we heard these songs yeah the
Drake [__] yeah so Drake and the weekend
join is fire yeah the songs are great
but like it's kind of remarkable how
quickly they've gotten good
yeah I mean it sounds like Travis Scott
you know how
women have been using like drag queen
makeup
contouring and these types of things or
traditional drag queen makeup and women
kind of like have absorbed it
so women's makeup is making them look a
little bit more trans
and then trans women the surgery and
[__] is getting better so they're kind
of like meeting in the middle
I think that's what's happening why the
AI music sounds so good because we're
distorting people's normal voices with
these like filters so there's these
audio filters so a guy like Travis Scott
is putting the audio auto tune on so
it's changing his voice and making it
more aiable AI Ariana
Grande no she's not like a robotic
singer she and I think academics posted
something but but I guess what I'm
trying to say is like when we went to uh
when we were in London we like sang in
that this booth and like they completely
changed my voice like to make it way
better than it was when we even did that
opener up song like I did not sound like
at all they completely distorted my
voice they're doing that with all of our
favorite artists whether they can sing
or not they are changing them
manipulating them so it's like it's just
getting closer to what a machine can do
and now they're meeting in the middle if
you compare and this would be the real
test you compare like Frank Sinatra
with AI Frank Sinatra because that's the
most pure version of it because they
didn't have all these tools to
manipulate how the person sounds I'm
fairly certain it will still be close
because again Ariana I've heard saying
live at like SNL or something one time
yeah she can say holy [__] here's a song
I just found I've never heard it before
this is Frank Sinatra singing Toxic by
Britney Spears okay get into it
um not even close to Frank Sinatra this
sounds like Fred Astaire yeah that's not
even close and there's a perfect example
and they just need more data and they
can eventually kind of figure it out but
Travis's voice is already AI so it's
easy to aim I think you can make Alex
sound like Travis or me sound like
Travis or you sound like Travis if you
just put enough autotune on yeah yeah I
will say the to the archives Point like
some of the ones like uh
like I think Rihanna did a Beyonce song
and it sounds identical to Rihanna like
again it's machineified like Rhonda's
voice is probably slightly machinified
but it still sounds if you play the
academics did post it Ariana Drake cover
I think and it's like yo this does not
sound like a robot the thing I think
everybody's talking about it just
because it's new tech and it's cool it's
like oh [__] let's see how this person
sounds singing somebody else's song But
at the end of the day no they have them
singing Hollywood dude they're speaking
a different language
I just think No One's Gonna Get like in
six months No One's Gonna care because
no one can put out a song saying hey
this is a Drake song and make money off
of it because they're going to get sued
and then this whole [__] is gonna stop
so this is just a cool little thing that
we all care about now of course I think
it's really going to be a thing will
they create remixes you know how we
enjoy remixes DJs come out and they make
these illegal remixes where they blend
different songs together yeah will they
start doing that with famous rappers
voices or famous singers voices and if
they're great we like a great song it
doesn't matter what it is
yeah right the moment that person puts
it out for sale then the record labels
just the best thing you don't need to
put it out for sale yeah like it can
just exist on the internet and then
become the new coolest thing and it's
almost like um people don't sell music
that way and all these Tick Tock songs
also like streaming sites once it's on a
streamer you're a profit yeah you can
but let's say that they're not profiting
on it it just uh it's just a popular
thing to use it's a video that we like
so man it helps the artist now it's just
another Banger for that artist and the
artist didn't have to do any work yep
yeah yeah yeah yeah and it's the same
thing that DJs are doing now already but
like there's a word a weird copyright
loophole where like if you do an
impression of someone's voice exactly
they don't get royalties for it you know
what I mean so like if a parody Lord
isn't it like you're allowed to like
it's an imitation like if you're able to
do a perfect Drake Weird Al Yankovic and
then you cover like a Rihanna song as
Drake and you can do a perfect accent he
doesn't get a cut of you doing a cover
that sounds like him you know what I
mean or like any of these bands that
sound like other artists like they don't
get a cut of it so if you could release
a song that has a feature from unknown
Canadian rapper and it's like if people
come up with pseudonyms for all of these
rappers like Canadian artists featuring
on my song and it sounds exactly like
Drake putting a fire verse on your track
is that Drake and is he entitled the
compensation it's just more work for
lawyers
oh that's good AI is gonna be like ah it
sounds dope
this has already been solved in in um in
film so you have the CGI rights to your
face and you can license your CGI right
so like uh what is the guy's name Bruce
Willis I think Bruce Willis yeah so
Bruce Willis licenses CGI rights and
there are other people who's really
really useful for him now yeah big time
but for real but think about it also
with like people are part of existing
franchises when they know that they're
probably going to die you wouldn't even
need to flip out Dumbledore if you know
you could do it right so Harrison Ford
he's doing a movie where he's aged down
and he said this is the first time it
seemed realistic so he signed on a Duo
but he's playing like a guy in his 50s
or whatever yeah so I think they'll just
do the same thing with your voice and we
know if it's [__] Drake's voice and
they'll find some way where it's like
has to be within five percentage points
so it's authentic and but that's if they
pass a law do they have a lot of like
like inhibits you they will have to pay
they will have they will once what
happens what I was talking about once it
becomes profitable once there's money
involved they're gonna find a way to get
their money and they deserve it the
problem that's coming with AI is that
it's moving so quickly I was reading
something about this the other week that
because laws take so long to get past by
the time laws are passed on ai ai will
be so much further ahead and then
they'll have to do it again yeah so law
isn't going to be able to keep up with
the race of AI and that's like a big
ethical problem with it yeah yeah I mean
they could theoretic we would probably
have to do the same thing for this pod
for our stand-up whatever
there's an AI Joe Rogan Experience it
isn't great yet but it's not there but
the point is and they say this at the
beginning this is to show how AI will
improve it's just going to get better
and better but episode one wasn't great
by episode 1 000 three years from now
yeah that [__] could be crazy exactly I
think they're quite a while fun jokes
and the reason I think that is so a
friend of mine is uh called Rebecca she
put into chat GPT and said write me a
joke in the style of Adam Rowe yeah now
they know when you're a comedian and
when you're not because she also put
write me a joke in the style of Rebecca
and then I say her name and I said I
apologize I'm not aware of a comedian
named Rebecca
but for me and you've got to understand
how offensive this was because this is a
robot that has took every bit of
information I've ever put on the
internet and this is the perfect
amalgamation it's come up with us like
this is something he would say I told my
girlfriend I wanted to spice up our
relationship so she bought me a paprika
Shaker I said I meant role play and now
every time we have sex she dresses up as
a chicken tikka masala
that was that is the internet
my entire body of wear into two
sentences and you're reading about this
thing it's like the smartest brain ever
it is the perfect brain it is a genius
machine and you're like this one he'd
say they chose the right setup though
because that was the joke that that I
saw from you that I was like hey you
should definitely open when I was in
London
yeah it was so funny but yeah yeah they
had me on the setup
[__] those Pacos man
they're always getting away